I wanna make sure that
I talk about your movie
which I watched last night.
Which I really enjoyed.
"Luckiest Girl Alive."
And I know this is an
important project for you,
'cause you're also a producer, right?
Yeah.
This was a book.
It was a book.
Yeah, it was a New York Times bestseller.
It's made up stories and
pictures, starring myself
and our you know, Orchard Farms
and with Netflix we did it.
Well, I'm super proud of it.
It's an amazing fun story.
Well, you tell me what
you think, but be honest.
I will be completely honest with you.
I thought you were fantastic.
And then there's also
an actress who plays you
at a younger age.
Chiara, yeah.
Chiara.
And it's very tricky,
because you're, you know,
you're a very well known iconic person,
and when you cut to the,
well you are, you mean
you're, you know, come on.
Thank you!
Mila Kunis.
So, when they cut to a younger Mila Kunis,
it's easy not to buy it.
And I thought she was fantastic.
I thought there was an amazing kind of
symbiotic attachment with you two.
Where I completely bought,
when they're cutting back to her,
that this is you at a younger age
and that you have what's
made you as an adult
is this trauma that you
had when you were younger.
And so I thought that was really well done
and really well played.
It's a tough thing to talk about
without giving away important.
I know.
I don't wanna give things away,
because there's a lot of illusion
to something that
happened to your character
when you were younger.
And it takes a while for you
to figure out what that is.
And I think that's really
important to the story.
So, I think it would
be, I'm not gonna say,
"Oh and this is what happens,"
because I think that's something
that makes the story that
much more compelling.
Yeah, it's a really hard movie
to pitch or to talk about.
Because you don't wanna, it's a fun ride.
I mean, it's a heavy topic,
so I'm not trying to
dilute by saying it's fun,
but it's an exciting
story to watch unfold.
I hope, I think.
And you don't wanna take
that away from the viewer.
'Cause there's two things that happen
that are really pinnacle
and really important.
So, when they happen,
one of them is definitely
a little bit more shocking
than the other I think.
It's something that I think
everybody should experience
on their own,
versus being told this is about to happen.
Being told, yeah.
The one thing that I think
doesn't give anything away,
which is a part of your performance
that I thought was very special.
Is you're playing someone
who is trying to repress
something that happened earlier,
and come across as perfect.
And so you're very angry,
you're sublimating all of it.
And that's something that
comes through really well,
is you've made yourself as an adult.
This person who's going through the world
who's really strong and
cool and sexy and smart
and living in Manhattan
and kind of invulnerable
and then we see that
it takes a huge effort
for you to be that person,
because you're compensating.
Yeah, that's a good way
of explaining it, yeah.
But that's, I mean, as an actor,
that's a very hard thing to pull off.
And you do that throughout the film,
which I think is really cool.
It's really fun.
To play somebody who's a little psycho.
Not like super, but just
a little unpredictable,
and putting on a show is
actually really fun to play.
I also had the luxury
of having the writer on
set with me all the time.
Who wrote the book and wrote the script,
who this is slightly
based off of her story.
And so, I know this sounds odd to say
for the content of the film;
but it was one of the most fun productions
I've ever been on.
And also when you're a
producer on the film as well,
does that?
I mean every role you do,
it feels like you are completely invested.
As an actor,
does anything change when
you're also producing?
Yes.
You start realizing what budgets are.
(everyone laughs)
I can just see you two going
by the craft service table.
Wait a minute, wait a minute,
wait a minute, wait a minute.
That's a lot of casserole.
And there's a lot of
tuna in the casserole.
There could be less tuna in the casserole,
'cause that stuff isn't cheap.
Yeah, yeah.
There's that.
I mean, it is.
You just understand where
your own money comes from.
Like, you realize, you're
like, I'm on a double.
Like you just realize, why
would I take for myself?
So, there's a difference there.
You wanna make sure everything happens.
Time is of the essence,
you realize what time
costs in preproduction,
you understand what setbacks are.
That as an actor would be like,
"Well that's their problem.
That is not my problem.
You figure out a new location."
and now I'm like, ugh, you
gotta go figure this out!
So, there's that.
And then you also are much more invested
in the outcome of the film.
So, you know, there's a
little bit more on it.
Like, if it's successful
then I'll be given the right
to produce more content as a producer.
But if it's, you know what I mean?
There's like, this is a
little bit of new territory.
So, you still have to
build up people's trust.
I had an experience this summer
where I was asked to be in
a film, not a huge role.
And I'd never done
anything like that before.
And it's not my jam.
And I never was interested
in being an actor.
But the people making the film
were people I really love.
And I was intrigued and I was like,
"Yeah, okay I'll do this."
This is a good time.
I'm not doing the late night show anymore,
so I gotta try this.
I couldn't believe how hard it is.
Oh really?
It's so different,
because what I'm used to, is
get in there, make the show.
They're both hard in their way.
I love 'em, but they're hard in their way.
But I couldn't believe how
hard everybody on a film works.
They're there all day.
all day.
Everyone's constantly on their feet.
I just, was blown away.
I really was impressed.
And afterwards, whenever
I had my last shot,
and they said, "Okay, you
know, we're wrapping Conan."
I just said,
"I have to tell you people,
I cannot believe how
hard all of you work."
And so now I see films differently.
I watch films and I think,
oh my God, to do this
scene with everybody.
Over, and over, and over.
From every angle and
know that you're there,
and know how many people are stepping in,
in between takes to make
sure everything's right,
and relighting.
It's an incredible amount of work.
I think the only reason I work out,
or most people work out.
Is to just have the energy
to work for 16 hour days.
Honestly.
Otherwise you're exhausted.
And your body takes a beating.
From like anybody.
From grips to any and
all those departments.
They have to be on their
feet all day, every day.
They're constantly listening
to voices in their heads.
So, it's like insane amount of noise
happening in their brain all the time.
Because of different channels
and people talking to each other.
They constantly have to be focusing.
It is an exhausting job.
Yeah, and again, there's a million vari...
I mean so many jobs out in
the world are extremely hard.
I just find it very, it always
amuses me when someone says,
"Man, you know, I'd
like to get into movies.
'Cause I wanna make money
and not have to work."
And I think, go see what these people do.
Just go see what these people do.
Yeah, I always say go be a PA.
Like, if you think you
wanna be in the industry
just be a PA on a film set for one movie.
And if you enjoy being you being a PA,
'cause PA's are the first
ones in, last ones out.
They're there for 18 hours.
And they don't get a trailer
to sit in, or a nice office.
I mean, it is grueling.
Anyways, yeah.
This was hard for me,
and I had incredibly lavish things.
I mean, my representation
made sure that I was massaged every hour.
You were pampered!
Oh my god!
Every scene I'm in, I'm in a bubble bath.
Which wasn't called for in the script.
That was just yours.
They just roll it in and I'm like,
"Hello gentlemen!"
"So, you're the murderer."
"Yes, I am."
And then they'd roll me out,
and it hurts the movie terribly.
What is this?
Oh, the movie is the the guys
from "Saturday Night Live,"
"Please Don't Destroy."
Yeah.
And they make these amazing shorts,
and they asked me if I would
do a small thing in their film
and I did and I adore them
and I love their work, and so.
Did you play Conan O' Brien?
No, that was the thing that I...
Oh, you played a character.
Yeah, 'cause you know,
when a talk show host is
in one of those things,
it's usually,
As a talk show host.
Yes.
You go in as a talk show host.
And that I got asked
to do a million times,
and I would do it.
And sometimes I show up
in a movie as, you know,
"Hi everybody, Conan here
and we're talking to,"
and you know, "Fake person!"
Who you know, was part of a movie.
And you're part of that reality
but it's not real.
But this, I got to be someone
who's very different from me,
which was fun.
Oh, that's exciting.
Acting.
Acting, Conan.
You're acting.
Oh, no, no, no.
I'm, yeah.
And I'm sure I'll be cut out.
It doesn't matter.
I had a really good experience
and as long as they send me the footage
I'm cut out of,
I'll be very happy about that.